when donald trump first took office he's
worth three and a half billion dollars
by the time that he left we estimated he
was worth 2.4 so that's a 1.1 billion
dollar drop now that's a lot of money
of course for anyone at any time but
especially when the market has been
doing
what it's been doing where it's been
soaring to have your
own personal fortune going the opposite
direction is a marker of bad business
in fact if trump had sold all his
businesses at the start of his
presidency
as many ethics experts suggested he
should have done
paid the maximum capital gains taxes on
the sales
then put the proceeds into a fund
tracking the s p
500 trump would have ended his
presidency an estimated 1.6
billion dollars richer than he is today
and he wouldn't have had to worry about
all the headaches for the last four
years
so how did he lose so much money in a
few years the first place to look is as
properties
so the one that lost the most money is
six east 57th street now
that's in midtown manhattan right around
the corner from trump tower
it used to be referred to as nike town
but in 2018 nike left
and then it was empty for a little while
while tiffany the jeweler
was working to move back in to sublease
from nike on a temporary basis
but tiffany is slated now to leave in
so all of a sudden you have this big
retail box in the center of manhattan
and that is exactly the sort of property
that has taken a beating over the last
handful of years if you think about it
if you wanted to go buy from a bunch of
high-end retailers
10 years ago 20 years ago you'd book a
trip to new york
and you'd walk down fifth avenue now if
you want to go buy from a bunch of
high-end retailers
all in an afternoon you do that from
your couch sitting anywhere
and so what that's done is that the
value of owning those
stores the actual real estate has
dropped
dramatically and that's hit donald trump
right there in that property and at some
of his other ones as well
another place trump lost money is his
once popular licensing business
which lost 163 million dollars over the
course of his presidency
once associated with luxury and success
the trump brand has taken a hit due to
the former president's polarizing
politics
suddenly when you become a president of
the united states and particularly one
as polarizing as he was
then you alienate 50 at least
of your potential customers and so a lot
of people now are like
i'm not going to pay to put donald
trump's name on my building
when right off the bat it means that i'm
going to lose 50 of the people who might
want to be in my hotel or buy condos
from me or whatever
so people are actually paying him now to
take his name off of buildings
and no one's coming in and stepping up
and saying we want to pay more
to put the name back on buildings and so
the value of that business
has dropped really dramatically and
kovitt didn't help trump either
his property at 40 wall street lost 195
million dollars of value during his
presidency losing 32
of its net operating income in the first
three quarters of 2020 alone
but not all of trump's properties lost
their value 555 california street in san
francisco increased its value by 102
million dollars during the trump
presidency
he has a 30 stake in the building which
is anchored by big tenants such as
goldman sachs and bank of america
both of whom renewed their leases at the
property another property that gained in
value is trump's winter white house
mar-a-lago
we now estimate that that property is
worth 250 million dollars and that's
a 75 million dollar increase from when
he took
office why is mar-a-lago up so much well
in the middle of the pandemic it seemed
like every rich billionaire new yorker
suddenly wanted to move from midtown
manhattan to
buy some huge estate in palm beach and
so people were
shelling out huge amounts of money for
residential real estate in palm beach
and who owns the nicest residential
property in palm beach donald trump
mar-a-lago
not only is it famous and historic but
it's just a beautiful
home so we believe that somebody would
pay upwards of 250 million dollars for
it today
and that's significantly more than they
would have four years ago and
even more significantly more than they
would have at the time that donald trump
bought it for just 10 million dollars
[Music]
you